i sadly am going to play for you today
some of the scariest audio and video
that we've had on the show for for a
while
we have seen people show up at
school boards or
city council meetings recently
and call for the killing of gay people
of lgbt people
today i'm going to play for you a clip
of a candidate
calling for the killing
of the parents of lgbt kids
this is candidate mark burns it might
not shock you
that mark burns is a trumpist he loves
trump he's pro-trump he is running in
the fourth district in south carolina
and he
called for the arrest and execution
of those who advocate for lgbt rights
and the protection of trans children
this was during an appearance on the stu
peters show and he talked about um
that he is committed to voting for
transphobic laws which will target lgbt
kids and their parents
and then he went further than saying he
will just vote for the legislation he
says he wants those parents held for
child abuse
and put to death if they are convicted
take a look at this this this is
extraordinarily dangerous the lgbt
transgender grooming our children's
minds is a national security threat now
by the way i hate to already interrupt
they you when republicans and
right-wingers get a new shiny toy in
this case it's the word grooming they
use it all the time
grooming has a very specific meaning uh
in the context of child abuse
and um
you know
saying to your kids i love you no matter
who you are
it's not really grooming it's actually
not at all grooming but they're just
using the word they're on the word
because it is ultimately designed to
destabilize the republic we call the
united states of america that's why when
i'm elected i don't want to just vote i
want to start holding people accountable
for treason to the constitution i am
going to push to reenact who act huac is
the house of on american activities
committee it was a real committee that
was formulated back in the 50s and it's
a committee that we should reenact that
starts holding these people accountable
for treason we need to hold people for
treason start having some public
hearings and start executing people who
are found guilty for their treasonous
acts against the constitution of the
united states of america do you
understand how insane that is
huak so first of all
i mean it putting to death the parents
of lgbt kids it it's
dangerously off the rails but there's
another aspect to this when we talk
about huak the house committee on
un-american activities
we're talking about mccarthyism we're
talking about a committee that looks at
whether americans have been disloyal
don't have to have committed any crime
it's just do you think the wrong things
which we have tagged
as being a lack of loyalty to the united
states
extraordinarily
dangerous candidate now does this guy
have a shot at winning well
we'll have to wait and see
would it be a shock to me
if this guy actually ended up getting
arrested for you know domestic violence
child porn whatever i'm not saying i
have any evidence of that but no
oftentimes the the loudest people who
say
let me one-up even you it's not enough
just to say i'm going to vote
i will demand the killing sometimes when
people go overboard like that
it's because they have things to hide we
don't know that to be the case with this
guy but that's something that we've seen
but we seem to live in a world where
people can freely express their desire
for large swaths of people to be killed
now i get it he's not personally
threatening to kill anybody
this is not the type of thing where you
would say well you know we're from the
police and we need to talk to you
but
the reaction is well yeah i mean just if
you don't like that don't vote for him
as if this counts as anything even
remotely approximating valid political
discourse uh i i it's
it's a it's it's increasingly dangerous
not only that people are saying these
things but they they aren't instantly
disqualifying and we go back to 2016
2015 trump and the access hollywood tape
in the entire thing
at a certain point in american political
history
the access hollywood grab them by the
you know what tape would have been a
disqualifier that would have been it
just no you you're done you resign
immediately and that's it it's over
and there is almost nothing that they
can't try to explain away at this point
in time now this guy is pro-trump trump
hasn't endorsed him so it's not a
situation where trump would pull his
endorsement or anything like that but
it's considered just like oh yeah well
no i'm against killing the people the
parents of lgbt kids so i'm not going to
vote for him this should be immediately
disqualifying and it's not in modern
american politics